une nouvelle fois hier soir les chaînes
de télévision se sont livrés une
bataille des audiences en remercie
france 3 a créé l'événement avec son
téléfilm le fond des oubliés et ses 4,7
millions d'aficionados la chaîne qui en
ce moment s'offre régulièrement la
première place des audiences
c'est le dr mamoun center on retrouve
ensuite la seconde demi finale de la
france a un incroyable talent avec 3,5
millions de téléspectateurs m6 s'appuie
sur le golden buzzer de médiamétrie et
se retrouve directement en seconde place
de ce classement
merci beaucoup autre ambiance autre
concours avec la finale de prodige des
prodiges qui ont attiré 2,9 millions
d'oreilles
ils vont nous du côté de tf1 décidément
les jours se suivent et se ressemblent
une fois encore la chaîne s'est retrouvé
quatrième des audiences avec pourtant un
film culte retour vers le futur défunt
n'a convaincu que 2,8 millions de
téléspectateurs soit un peu plus de 12%
du public
inutile d'insister vous n'avez aucun
avait un échec pour tf1
rappelons qu'en 2015 la chaîne tmc avait
attiré près de 2 millions
téléspectateurs en diffusant le second
volet de la saga
alors êtes vous choqué que tf1 soit
quatrième chaîne des audiences en prime
oui alors voilà il ya 19h52 alors on
dépend directement des projets voilà
voilà parce que je vois là oui moi je
pense que ça doit alors faire les pieds
à tf1 de se retrouver quatrième des
audiences et d'être battu par des
chaînes qui ont beaucoup moins de budget
que moi faut tard c'est au sort oui mais
là moi je voulais défendre et à la fin
l'action fiche complètement chan a quand
même dur c'est dur d'être battue par m6
par france 2 par france inscrit le savez
savez la direction il ya dix ans jamais
il aurait mis un prime en disant on va
être quatrième des audiences à
n'existait pas il ya dix ans ils ont
toujours méprisé les autres chaînes moi
j'ai bossé chez tf1 pendant longtemps à
raison toujours est et moi je rappelle
en 2012 j'étais chez tf1 et je regardais
ppm pc quand vous arriviez sur d8
oui et je regardais j'ai débuté il ya
plein de trucs bien dans l'émission
devrait faire pareil et c'est ce que je
bossais sur danse avec les stars comme
simon s'en fout ça fait trois cent mille
en sont fous etc
ils ont toujours été méprisant et
aujourd'hui se font battre par des
chaînes qui ont trois fois moins de
budget que c'est vrai que je pense qu'il
faut qu'il se remette en question avez
vous êtes parti de tf1 où est ce que je
suis allé chez europe 1 tf1 prod cette
fois tf1 prod avec preuve à oui il faut
parfois les mêmes concepts d'autres sont
les appeller nicolas pernikoff non je
pense qu'ils ont essayé de faire un
choix économique mais un choix derrière
eux un choix dont je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que m6 a abandonné je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez avait
capital et zone interdite aux débuts de
m6 qui était très peu
sans le dimanche soir à un moment donné
ça commençait à descendre des centres
décembre et qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
ils ont commencé à lancer la nouvelle
star un dîner presque parfait et plein
de nouvelles émissions pour essayer de
redonner envie aux gens insuffler une
nouvelle énergie jacques te mens une
nouvelle énergie
du coup capital et zone interdite se
sont montées à ce moment là sauf
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une multitude de
chaînes
donc si tf1 fait ce job demain ça va
leur prendre des mois et des mois ça
pour arriver à recruter et de fidéliser
des téléspectateurs donc je pense que
leurs choix économiques et ultra
dangereux stratégiquement oui mais c'est
un choix
c'est un joueur mais quoi sans vous
savez ça mettrait d'accord avec valérie
savait hier soir qu'ils étaient les deux
sens sont des millions d'euros cette
année
donc il ya un vrai trou dans le budget
de sa question
c'est comme lui il a perdu 270000 euros
avec ces femmes ont beaucoup plus
voiture c'est vrai vous plaît beaucoup
plus à lui aurait préféré dit à peu près
comme mauvais et perdu avec vos femmes 7
millions j'ai donné de puissance et ça
c'est pas vrai mais benji vous êtes
magnifique il faut assumer des biens sur
bravo
on est la seule émission est un mec qui
personne
déjà cédé sommes tous à examiner ce
n'est pas parce que quelqu'un dit je
suis libanaise déjà de sony cédant 7
millions je paie plus de 300 millions
d'euros par an non oui si vous gagnez
vous avez les directions mais c'est
normal dans l'airé gagner des sommes
incroyables c'est tout à fait normal moi
j'ai pas là pour le coup quand on se
marie on a des enfants tout ça très
normal de payer bon après j'ai payé
beaucoup mais bon et qui a coûté le plus
cher
non moi savoir
tu dois savoir eh ben le solde ira pas
parce qu'on est bien élevé voilà je suis
ronde et bien élevé que les bains si on
ne dira pas ce pour bien sûr sur ce tour
tf1 quand même important vous avez perdu
7 pineau non ils sont ils pas perdu non
stéphane quand même fait la plus grosse
erreur stratégique de son histoire rap
et il ne croyait pas s'arrêter on
croyait pas du tout à la tnt quand la
tnt s'est lancé ça c'est vrai pas pris
le virage arrêtez avec ça âgé à voir
quand j'ai mal au ventre alors dégâts
sur près de 7 me
ces trous n'ont pas pris c'est vrai que
maintenant quelque part et c'est très
peu plus compliqué pour une époque où
j'étais le n'y croyait absolument pas
aujourd'hui si on cumule la tnt ça fait
quoi de 10-12 millions parfois un riche
oui c'est pas qu'il faudrait pas louper
un autre virage parce que vous parler
d'économie moi j'y connais rien mais là
ils ont loupé le virage de la tnt ils
sont peut-être pas en train de louper un
virage 10 ans on économise en économie
ce que les gens quand ils sont partis
les téléspectateurs c'est peut-être moi
je la vis est d'accord avec nicolas
c'est peut-être compliqué après deux
tartines question pose toi moi je pense
que en fait saisi neuf jamais là le film
ça fait genre des centaines de fois
qu'il a été rediffusé évidemment que les
genres engagement puis à d'autres
émissions des choses plus intéressantes
alors je vais vous dire on parle de
téléphone deux jours de suite parce que
ça fait deux jours du démarrage toujours
les émissions par les audiences de la
veille
un jour un moment que tf1 va être
premier donc on voit là on dira que tf1
ait problème rien mais là c'est vrai que
son quatrième est incroyable voilà oui
delphine le truc c'est que le slogan de
tf1 c'est partageons partageons des
zombies il met toujours des séries
américaines pour moi c'est plus
anxiogène qu'autre chose la science dit
à roger aurat froide usap il ya que de
la bière des tarots je viens en venant à
bout des tarots g ya qu' il n'y a que ya
que du téléfilm américain il ya que les
mêmes assez vite on est même invité sur
les plateaux aussi et moi je trouve que
ça mériterait un peu plus de chaleur un
peu moins d'élitisme et plus de
proximité avec les téléspectateurs
je change beaucoup accroché que j'adore
voilà il est gênant c'est de delphine
way échange beaucoup par sms avec lui et
on s'entend très bien tous les deux elle
avoue sait pas on échange on est des
petits cm ça allait mais mémoire la tête
fillon sont bas si un jour ils venise
promis de la faire je m'en vais et qui
repart avec 7 millions ce sera toutefois
d'être un casse tête
oui on est obligé de donner la parole et
précision mais qui concerne tous les
groupes privés y compris les combrit ses
huit ans c'est qu'il ya quand même et
60% de perdre le marché publicitaire
s'ils vont à l'économie quand même parce
qu'il faut finir voilà que nous
ça se voit plus sur tf1 que chez nous
est ce que parce que forcément quand y'a
une redif ça se remarque sur tf1 oui
c'est vrai que dans la raison se croient
à la raison sur un truc ils ont acheté
des cires américaine manifeste c'était
une cata mais l'autre là tout est une
canaille se sont plantés sur la charge
ici en amérique et ça a été un drame oui
qu'est ce qu'on attend de tf1 on attend
de voir des choses qu'on peut avoir sur
les autres chaînes qui crée l'événement
à l'époque il avait les cheveux pas la
finale de la ligue des champions par
exemple qu'ils ont diffusé cette année
là ils font des scores doses alors c'est
pas très bien la finale des as et cette
année ça leur rapporte pas beaucoup
d'argent ça alors c'est wings étaient
ses terres pertes
oui mais au moins ça crée l'événement
sarr qui se passe déjà se passer des
choses sur tf1 qu on pouvait pas voir
ailleurs là retour vers le futur je peux
le voir sur tmc je me voir sur w9 bars
les commerces et la soirée à l'écran tft
rappelez vous que tf1 a quand même
revendu à m6 des matchs de foot de
l'équipe de caces oui oui oui
donc c'est quand même un signe ça veut
dire que c'est plus compliqué pour eux
oui la baffe à roger le seul côté
terroir et proximité sur tf1 c'était le
journal de jean-pierre pernaut et
maintenant ils vont plus la voir ou est
ce qu'il y aura en tous cas le pardon un
peu proximité chaleur run je dirais
c'est tranquille un pied déjà c'est
france 3 qui l'a rattrapé et france 3
cartonne
oui mais voilà c'est vous allez voir la
fia le concours des régions qui arrive
la semaine prochaine sur france 3
vendredi soir je vous le dis spécial
cuisine je sens que ça ça va être un 46
millions je vous le dis je les vois par
le vent tf1 parce que l'économie vous
parler d'économie sur tf1 mais vous
croyez que les programmes que mais
france 2 france 3 et m6 coûte plus cher
que les programmes qu'ils mettaient fin
à leur mission mais par trois et non non
non je suis de droite et brun tu fais
prodige quand tu fais la fraude ou
l'amour fait d'accord oui ça coûte un
million de quintaux soit par rapport au
sérieux alors je pense qu'ils ont aussi
le budget pour proposer autre chose
qu'un film qu'on a regardé quand on est
en sixième mais parce que retour vers le
futur je tends 6e et 7e année elle était
même pas les regarder de 2,2 fait qu'on
ne sait pas
les 100 premiers tous les jours c'est
vrai on se trouve si vous m'expliquez
web mais ces voix là c'est au 6 mai mais
parfois ça retombe votants vers le futur
il est sur netflix
donc c'est pas du tout bénef pour eux de
le mettre sur tf1 sur fois d'être suivi
c'est en effet ce qu'est l'intérêt que
vous avez même les olivier marchal après
j'arrête je vais me prendre pour un
spécialiste est ridicule vous avez même
money mais marchal qui fait des films
maintenant sur netflix même tf1 n'est
pas capable de faire venir les cinq dr
fait cela te dis ça remplace les deux ça
remplace m
mais quand vous regardez d'un clic vous
regardez pas la télé le soir de
téléphonie sur une autre chaîne il voulu
le faire au cinéma au départ